ladies and gentlemen begrüßen sie
gemeinsam mit medien soeben aus mailand
zurück in köln gelandeten mode manager
fashion-ikone und allgemein heißt es der
typ der welt löschen und zu nutzen
die limited great race
[Musik]
endlich bin ich nun auch als herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video auf seinem youtube kanal meine
lieben freunde ihr seht es bereits im
titel eingeblendet und zwar schauen uns
heute die gntm kandidatinnen des
diesjährigen jahres 2001 und das jetzt
die erste kandidatin mit dem namen
victoria sie trägt hier einen grünen
blazer kombiniert mit zwei gelben
karabinerhaken in den ohren
die viktoria hat einen extrem langen
text über sich ihr steht hier tm
-kandidaten victoria hat großes vor sie
möchte nicht nur die fußstapfen ihrer
schwester treten sondern die bestenfalls
auch übertreffen denn ihre schwester
julia k medienteam 2000 leute nur die
top ten war deinen vater und deine
mutter auch bei gm damals meine
schwester ist die julia vom letzten jahr
keine ahnung
und sie werden der top ten ist als
zehnte dann ausgestiegen jetzt hoffe ich
dass ich das gleiche erleben kann wie
meine schwester auf
wirst du nicht
sie enthalten ist ja jedes jahr
unterschiedlich allgemeine jetzt mal
ganz kurz bevor wir jetzt hier weiter
auf die leute reagieren ich meine hier
überhaupt nicht böse oder keine ahnung
was es ist einfach nur mein humor also
ich habe hier ich kenne keine personen
von denen persönlich ich habe nichts
gegen irgendwelche personen aber ich
finds halt manchmal lustig wie die dann
in interviews her ja ich will einfach
nur besser wäre das meine schwester als
ihr euch übrigens die ganzen interview
für den angucken wollte also jede
kandidatin hat hier in zwei minuten
interview irgendwie so ein kurzes video
auf ihrer seite ein link dazu es auf
jeden fall und in der beschreibung
findet ihr die topmodel seite haben hier
ist nichts irgendwie verdient mit der
sendung oder so aber ich hätte ihn tmn
bekanntgeworden 1938 in bulgarien als
die fresse du lappen das war allerdings
auf jeden fall die erste gntm kandidatin
2020 namens victoria wir machen
allerdings direkt weiter mit der
anastasia das ist die zweite neue
kandidatin und die das sieht so ein
bisschen so aus wie wenn man wenn man so
angst vor strahlen aliens hat aber alles
klar okay anastase klingen ja auch hier
wieder die ist
gntm kandidatin anastasia ist mit ihren
16 jahren eine denk jüngsten
teilnehmerinnen bei germany's next
topmodel 2020 dennoch ist sie überzeugt
sie steht ihren älteren mitstreiterin in
nichts nach
doch im alter oder so mal da bla bla bla
bla hier erfährt man noch ein bisschen
mehr aber sie neben dem titel germany's
next topmodel 2020 wünscht sich anders
da sehen die top ten der tennis-welt 38
das ist die anastasia tiefe gespielt
werden und danach wieder in der
weltrangliste danach bis jetzt erstmal
trotzdem war's und als erster die
gefährten besteigen
normale ziele einer 16-jährigen überall
wo sie irgendwie rankommt bekommt ihr
auch mal zum glück ich habe jetzt schon
vor angst ist jetzt irgendwie 12 13
jährige mädchen sich das hier anschauen
von mir und sich denken was ist glück
für ein arschloch der disti alle voll
das ist natürlich alles nicht böse
gemeint ich weiß jetzt dass gerade schon
bei der ersten kandidaten gezählt
sondern was zu zweit und jetzt will ich
es auch nicht mehr sagen aber das ist
einfach ironisch gemeint so nehmt euch
das bitte nicht zu herzen
letztes jahr habe ich das auch ganz
lustig letztes jahr habe ich auch auf
die gntm kandidatin 2009/10 reagiert vor
dem beginn der show und es gab eine
person die ich auf jeden fall direkt
rausgeschmissen hätte das war nämlich
die mode und die wird nachher germany's
next topmodel
also haltet euch nicht fest aber einen
dummen kommentare nicht gar keine ahnung
außer wenn es um louis vitton fashion
pieces die nächste kandidatin ist auf
jeden fall die liebe aline wie scrollen
die direktwahl runter sie ist 22 kompott
becker was haben die denn da alle film
roman stehen so viel hatte ich ja nicht
mal meine abiprüfung hingeschrieben wie
kommt auf jeden fall aus münchen und wir
sehen ja auch schon mal allgemein awards
0 von zehn shootings nur von sind okay
okay
wow auf der website wird diesmal alles
zusammengefasst hallo ich bin ja wie
[Musik]
alina die kommt auch aus münchen lasst
uns einfach die berichte wo sieht runter
paten gefunden
wir machen weiter mit der nächsten
kandidaten und zwar ist es die
kandidatin mit dem namen nina
suzuki nimmt die nasa sowie die nase die
ihn als sprachen lernen will
es ist auf jeden fall die hier das ist
die in asyl sie hat die hat dani hat und
sie
ich frag
was die analysten müllsack hier also ich
bin ja nicht cool ich habe schon in
mailand in rom und paris gearbeitet
aber was den kandidaten teilweise
anziehen
freunde alles nur spaß hier auf jeden
fall wir kriegen auch hier mal auf mehr
sie hat ein bisschen den kürzeren texas
ist ziemlich cool weil dann kann ich den
auch lesen weil wächst so langsam
verlieren ich zwischendrin kurz mal das
leben ihm asyl ist ein kreativer mensch
und arbeitet als grafikdesigner dann
auch in ihrer freizeit zeichnet sie
gerne und macht sport und tanz siehst du
das ist so richtig erst gar nicht nach
amerika war das video von der nina
annahmen ich bin 19 jahre alt kommen aus
der nähe von münchen
warum bekommt sie keine bayerische die
wichtigen fragen hier na ja gut das war
auf jeden fall die nasa
als die glaube ich - und das hat sich so
ein schlaflied für babys und nina
[Musik]
korrekt ich habe mir mal das ist auf
jeden fall die nächste kandidatin mit
dem namen cassandra 27 jahre alt und
verwaltungsfachangestellte wow das ist
eine lange berufsbezeichnung eine
berufsbezeichnung ist einfach lauch
ja eigentlich sollte ich meinen kanal
löschen tamara ist auf jeden fall die
nächste gntm kandidatin sie sieht ein
wenig so aus als würden die anderen
mädchen nicht so gern mit kirschen essen
wollen glaube ich komm mal runter sie
ist 19 jahre kommt aus wien tamaras
wurzeln liegen in mazedonien sie hat
einen hand hand handschuhe abschluss
handelt wahrscheinlich als die nach
schulabschluss flughafen eine kleine
kammer preis verkaufen sarah s punkt ist
die nächste kandidaten
sie hat eine schach muster jacke hear
what ever an
jetzt kommt mal runter die saga kommt
aus köln das erste mal dieses jahr das
auch reifenwechsel unternehmen weit
hinterher
bitte versteht wirklich dass hiervon
nicht böse gemeint ist nicht ob wir
können einfach mit mir lachen ich find's
einfach total amüsant mich über
teilweise echt ausgefallene mode lustig
zu machen
obwohl sich heute dabei wirklich
gedanken gemacht haben möchte ich
allerdings nicht dass sich irgendjemand
verletzt oder angegriffen fühlt wir
haben noch sieben kandidatinnen und ich
bin in der rodacher bei 45 minuten was
ist denn los
[Musik]
es gibt noch mehr kandidatinnen ich
würde sagen wir haben jetzt einfach noch
ein paar kandidaten denn hier zum ende
des videos durch wenn ihr allerdings
einen zweiten teil wollte den ich
beispielsweise morgen oder übermorgen
dann hochladen mit den restlichen
kandidatinnen so dass ich dann wirklich
auf alle gntm 2020 kandidatin reagiert
habe das den daumen hoch und dann wieder
hebamme bei 40.000 likes kommt dann
morgen oder übermorgen teil 2 aber wir
schauen uns jetzt daria hier an darya
ist fahrzeug technische assistentin
ursprünglich kommt ihre familie aus
kasachstan daher spricht daher auch
fließend russisch schon als kind wollte
die model werden und hat heimlich die
kleidung und hohen schuhe ihrer mutter
angezogen
das habe ich tatsächlich auch mal
gemacht
die nächste kandidatin weil er lieben
freunde astana stars ja ich habe gesagt
wir hast du jetzt hier ein bisschen
schneller einfach durch verwendetes
videos 20 jahre schülerin und kommt aus
berlin an dass da sie ja die russische
tochter russin krass das ist wieder so
komplett diversity soll werden leute aus
dem senegal haben wir schon gehabt dann
hatten wir eine aus bulgarien
da wurde ich hab damals stoffwechsels
allerdings besucht die anastasia derzeit
die gymnasiale oberstufe und schon als
kind wollte sie model wert und konnte
mit 14 jahren in japan bereits erste
model erfahrungen sammeln in japan
da habe ich mehrere wochen wurden die
fünf kandidatinnen wir uns heute
anschaut ist liebe mareike ihr seht
schon an der art wie sie hier steht wie
sie guckt und anhand ihrer tattoos kann
man das ja auch mal so ein bisschen
erkennen dass die wahrscheinlich erste
typ ist und von rene adler und gebe ich
denke ich wird eine kandidatin sein die
ein bisschen anecken wird allerdings hat
die steuer noch nicht angefangen von
daher kann ich jetzt noch nicht richtig
beurteilen wenn es nach eher das
gegenteil der fall wenn wir dann werden
wieder alle 1000 kommen
das hier ist die vierte letzte
kandidatin namens lucia aber sie ist 21
jahre alte koo ist studentin und kommt
aus kassel jetzt studenten und eine
selbstbewusste lebensfroher und
lebensfroh auch ich hab ich habe
farbenfroh gelesen und sie dann einfach
nur aber nein hier steht sie ist eine
lebensfrohe und aufgeschlossene junge
frau mit 18 jahren hat sie sich als
transsexuell geoutet und geht seitdem
offensiv mit dem thema um denn sie fühlt
sich jetzt sowohl wie noch nie gab
ich habe wirklich das finde ich cool
oder haben sie dann teilweise wirklich
das hat man schon gesehen so erste
päckchen eingestellt und mittlerweile
ist es so komplett diverse teams also
bei der lucy bin ich auf jeden fall auch
gespannt wie sie sich schlagen wird
das jetzt auf jeden fall die drittletzte
kandidaten die wir uns heute anschauen
nämlich die liebe berlin berlin ist 21
jahre alt auszubildende aus berlin und
marin macht derzeit eine ausbildung zur
erzieherin
ja ich glaube ich
aber wieder neu gezogen werden der
merlin finde ich kann man überhaupt
nicht einschätzen jetzt im vorhinein
ohne als ich ab die alle noch nie
gesehen getroffen oder die man ihn jetzt
noch nicht mal das interview angeschaut
aber wenn man sich jetzt einfach mal so
das aussehen das äußere anguckt würde
ich denken die ketten und die
augenbrauen das wird wirkt bisschen
aggressiv aber dann halt wieder sonnen
jackett und sohn rollkragenpulli der so
ein bisschen so hey liebes erzogen das
mädchen bin ich ganz interessant so sich
vorher mal gedanken zu machen hey wie
könnten die leute vielleicht persönlich
sein wie wird das in der schau macht er
sein also könnt ihr mal und in die
kommentare schreiben die mir hier gute
chancen zu rechnet wem nicht vor letzte
kandidatin nicht uns heute anschauen
dass die liebe da den sie hat einen
riesigen schlüssel umhängen das ist
nämlich der schlüssel zu meinem herzen
adidas junia supply chain manager und
hat schon für verschiedene zwecke
gemodelt 2017 war die wiesn madl in
ihrer freizeit fährt sie am liebsten
motorrad oder motocross diese
leidenschaft teilt sie trotz eines
unfalls vor zwei jahren mit ihrer
familie ihren freunden drei jahre jünger
als ich und hat 30.000 mal so viel
erlebt wie ich in meinem leben nun
allerdings wird es auch schon zur
letzten gntm kandidatinnen die wir uns
heute anschaut werden uns was die liebe
saskia hat einen coolen style community
weiß mit rot und beige rolle man ein
bisschen mehr darunter saskia ist 22
jahre alt studentin aus dem braunschweig
und es ein temperamentvoller mensch der
immer für spontane aktionen zu
begeistern ist
sie liebt es ständig neues zu erleben
und zu entdecken die studentin konnte
erst motto aber die haben ja alle schon
model erfahrungen
du dich mich damals 16-jährigen ein
bisschen verarscht vorkommen
allerdings will ich an der stelle das
heutige wir jetzt beenden meine lieben
freunde wie bereits mehrfach erwähnt
möchte ich mit meinen aussagen niemanden
hier beleidigen weder kandidatinnen
schikanieren negativ darstellen oder
sonst irgendwas tun sondern das ist
alles rein ironisch gemeint als scherz
zu verstehen ich hoffe dass auch er das
als zuschauer und langjährige gntm fans
so wie ich das auch wenn versteht wenn
ihr einen zweiten teil von mir mein
meinen reaktion auf meinen wie ich kann
ich kann nicht mehr reden ich bin in der
rodacher bei einer stunde 17
eines nachts wenn jetzt wenn ihr möchtet
dass sich noch auf die restlichen
kandidatinnen reagiere dann wie bereits
gesagt lass einen daumen hoch dabei
40.000 likes wirte morgen oder
übermorgen ein zweiter teil hierzu
kommen okay bis dann
[Musik]